Breaking Bad is regarded as one of the
finest TV shows in recent years but
while few people disagree with the
show's greatness even such a
well-crafted series is bound to leave
some plot points unresolved or write
itself into a corner now and then
so which plot point bothers us the most
in the season 5 episode confessions
Jesse Pinkman experiences a
game-changing revelation that has an
explosive impact on his storyline
however how jesse reached his conclusion
feels a little overly convenient if not
downright contrived even now years after
Breaking Bad has wrapped the details of
the episode continued to be debated
among fans in confessions after Walter
White's DEA brother-in-law Hank tries to
get a confession from Jesse about Walt's
drug empire Walt's attorney saw Goodman
interrupts and takes Jesse to Walt who
convinces Jesse to escape to another
city and take on a new identity
meanwhile Walt tapes a fake confession
framing Hank for his own drug dealings
making it difficult for Hank to move
forward with drug charges against Walt
has been building a meth Empire for over
a year now and using me as his chemist
all in all it looks like Walt is doing a
pretty good job keeping himself safe
however no sooner has Jesse agreed to
drop off the grid than he rifles through
his pockets and has a pivotal
realization at first he's looking for
his small cache of marijuana but
discovers that it's missing while
looking for it Jesse's fingers float
across a pack of cigarettes it's in this
moment he has a realization he didn't
lose his marijuana Saul's bodyguard
Huell sneakily took it off him that
leads him to realize that Huell had
previously stolen the pack of cigarettes
containing the poisonous ricin cigarette
intended to kill drug lord Gustavo Fring
which Jesse believes was used to poison
his girlfriend's son Brock still Saul
admits that Walt asked him to lift the
ricin cigarette but that he didn't know
what it was for after realizing that
Walt lied to Jesse about what happened
to the ricin Jessie reaches a tipping
point this somewhat convoluted set of
circumstances involving ricin and
cigarettes has been discussed again and
again over the years at the time that
confessions aired Jesse's sudden
epiphany caused a lot of confusion among
fans who themselves had lost track of
the ricin plot threat
in fact the rice and narrative goes all
the way back to season 2 during which
Walt makes a batch of the poison to kill
the ruthless Salamanca drug distributor
Tuco it also connects to another plot
from season 4 with Walt making another
batch of ricin which Jesse hides in a
cigarette
not long after Brock is poisoned and
Jesse is convinced by Walt that Gus
fring was behind the poisoning
however in confessions Jesse comes to
the conclusion that Walt used a ricin
cigarette to poison Brock boys drugged
you eugen while jesse is wrong about the
type of poison he's right about the act
itself it just turns out that Walt used
poisonous berries on Brock not ricin
it's understandable that fans were not
only confused about all these plot
points spanning multiple seasons but
also about how Jesse managed to piece
together such a complex chain of events
with just a few seconds and no real
evidence even for Breaking Bad this
development veers into day use mocking a
territory in which an event conveniently
happens out of nowhere for the sake of
the plot the ricin cigarette itself
could easily feel like a gear of the
narrative very obviously wedged into
place to push events in a certain
direction one obvious explanation for
this still bothersome plot point is that
in a way Jesse always knew who was
really behind Brock's poisoning Jesse
knows better than anyone about Walt's
potential for cruelty and treachery
because he's been side by side with him
in the meth ring since day one
throughout the series Jesse calls out
Walt for lying to him and toying with
him it's not a stretch for Jesse to
conclude that Walt had something to do
with Brock's poisoning by waiting until
the last possible second to force
himself to acknowledge the truth the
show's writers gave Jesse the
opportunity to resolve his character arc
as a pawn of Walt's jesse had always
struggled with personal agency finally
during confessions he turns his fate
around and goes from a passive
participant in his own life to an active
one however some complained that Jesse's
convenient realization about the ricin
cigarette feels more like a leftover
plot point representing a moment of
incompetence on the part of the writers
these fans don't appreciate that the
deus ex machina drags Walt and the
series to a predetermined end point
Jesse often thought about Brock's
poisoning and how his relationship with
Walt put Brock and Andrea into grave
danger
brach nearly died and at the end of the
show andrea was murdered as a way to
intimidate Jesse after he attempted to
flee from Todd and his dangerous family
if Jesse had never gotten mixed up with
Walt Brock never would have been
poisoned
if he hadn't partnered with Walt in the
meth making biz Jesse also wouldn't have
met Todd and Andrea wouldn't have been
killed
similarly if Jesse hadn't struck up a
romantic relationship with Andrea she
wouldn't have been exposed to his
criminality and the bad guys around him
Andrea would be alive and Brock wouldn't
have been harmed you know jesse pinkman
jesse isn't directly responsible for
Brock's poisoning or for Andrea's murder
but he feels guilty all the same at the
end of the 2019 Netflix film El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie Jesse heads to Alaska
to begin a new life following the events
of the series just before he leaves he
hands edy Galbraith a goodbye letter
written to Brock the ending of El Camino
was originally meant to feature a
voiceover of Jesse reading the note for
Brock but viewers never got to hear that
or see what was inside the envelope
jesse pinkman actor Aaron Paul told TV
Guide that Jesse's letter to Brock was
quite emotional and was actually the
first thing that Breaking Bad creator
Vince Gilligan wrote for El Camino
although the content of the letter had
to be cut from the final film Paul hopes
fans can hear Jesse's apology to brock
someday it's just the most honest
beautiful caring letter imaginable check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you